[Music]
it's seven o'clock this is a sky news
special on the war in ukraine from here
in the city of la viv our top story an
ominous warning from the prime minister
boris johnson tells sky news he fears
russia's president may deploy chemical
weapons here in ukraine
the stuff that you're hearing about
chemical weapons this is straight out of
their playbook
worlds apart the highest level talks
between both sides conclude with no
agreement on a ceasefire
victims of strikes in mario poll are
buried in mass graves as the attacks
continue
the former head of nato says military
action by the west should not be ruled
out
we are confronted with a political
gangster in the kremlin
and in defense against gangsters you
should not exclude any action
and unable to buy players or sell
tickets chelsea feels the sharp end of
sanctions on its owner roman abramovich
[Music]
good evening the prime minister has told
sky news that he fears president putin
could deploy chemical weapons as part of
russia's invasion of this country boris
johnson has been speaking exclusively to
our political editor beth rigby
i'll make you one other prediction by
the way which is that the stuff that
you're hearing about
uh
chemical weapons is straight out of
their playbook they start saying that
there are chemical weapons that have
been stored by
their opponents or by the americans and
so when they themselves deploy uh
chemical weapons as i as i fear they
they may they have us a a sort of a
masculine a fake story ready to go and
you've seen it in syria uh you you saw
it in even in the uk when this is what
you expect next then look i you know
it's i i just note that that is what
they're they're already doing it is a
cynical uh barbaric uh
government i'm afraid
let's go live to westminster and our
chief political correspondent john craig
so john why is boris johnson bringing
this up now
prime minister wants to hammer home the
message that we first heard yesterday
from western officials
who warned of a syrian style chemical
attack uh following the brutal attack on
the maternity hospital in ukraine now uh
that uh uh warning from the uh officials
uh was prompt then prompted the white
house press secretary that's jen
to talk about false claims when the pm
talks about a fake story the white house
is using the phrase false claims about
alleged u.s biological weapons labs and
chemical weapons deployments in ukraine
and uh the
the white house has said we should all
be on the lookout for russia to possibly
use chemical or biological weapons uh
liz truss earlier on today she's in
washington uh said we're very concerned
about the potential use of chemical
weapons uh we've seen russia use these
weapons before in fields of conflict and
uh
that to be a grave mistake a phrase the
pm's muse many times the prime minister
said in his interview with beth rigby
there you've seen it in syria you saw it
even in the uk that obviously is a
reference to the salisbury uh poisoning
a few years ago and uh this is a warning
we are likely to hear uh
reinforced over the in the coming days
from boris johnson and indeed senior
ministers like liz trust and
and no doubt the defense secretary ben
wallace it's a message we'll hear from
both london and washington but the prime
minister has spelled it out very clearly
in his interview with beth rigby here on
sky news
okay john thank you very much well you
can watch beth rigby's exclusive
interview with the prime minister in
full
this evening here on sky news that's on
her new programme beth rigby interviews
this evening at
nine o'clock
let's go then to our security and
defense editor deborah haynes who's here
with me in western ukraine
and this
issue of the potential use of chemical
weapons debra how seriously will nato be
taking this
well let's just sort of talk about what
it what it could mean i mean in terms of
chemical weapons which are banned
remember this is like a it's a violation
of international law to use chemical
weapons on the battlefield it was a red
line that
then president obama drew during the
syria conflict
and then allowed russia and russia's the
russia-backed
syrian regime to cross that red line
with the use of chemical weapons sarin
gas attacks
in syria without the overwhelming
consequences that should have ensured
that that
that violation of international norms
wasn't allowed to go unpunished in a way
that would deter
future use and that's one of the reasons
frankly that we are where we are today
with ministers uh even talking about
this interesting talking about the
possibility of it happening but not
offering any suggestion of a threat that
would deter the use of that
from happening which i think really
again underlines the difficulty that
western allies have with this conflict
they obviously are supporting the
ukrainian forces but they aren't going
so far that they would put themselves in
direct comp military confrontation with
russia um and so it's a really difficult
balancing act um and in terms of why
we're even thinking about this it has a
lot to do with how badly the war is
going for russia i mean here we are
we're in the third week now of this
invasion and russia has yet to capture
and significantly hold territory yes it
has taken her son for example in the
south but you're still seeing ukrainian
protests on the street anti-russian
protests there's no sense of them making
any significant meaningful movement on
the capitol
and in desperation in frustration
perhaps um you escalate up the violence
and that's the kind of threat that we're
seeing and that's why you're getting
these warnings
okay deborah thank you very much well
the most high level diplomatic talks in
the conflict so far have failed to make
any progress today russia's sergey
lavrov demanded that ukraine be disarmed
denazified and accept neutral status
ukraine said russia's demands amounted
to asking them to surrender meanwhile
bombardments have continued in several
cities here aid authorities have tried
to open several humanitarian corridors
today to evacuate civilians from
besieged towns and cities the priority
was to get people out of mariopol
where three people including a child
were killed in yesterday's strike on a
hospital the city has been blockaded by
russia for nine days now but no one was
evacuated today at all and the city was
once again under attack from the air
emergency services report that more than
twelve thousand civilians did manage to
leave
the region of sumi successfully today
the governor of isiam which has been
under constant attack reports that 1 600
people
evacuated that town today and people
continue to escape fierce fighting in
towns on the outskirts of kiev a steady
stream of people has been crossing a
makeshift bridge from urban towards the
relative safety of the capital
meanwhile
ukraine's military says russia is
continuing its strategy of shelling
major cities around the country
well today's talks failed to reach any
significant announcements on ceasefires
or humanitarian humanitarian corridors
diplomatic editor dominic waghorn
reports now from turkey
in the besieged city of mariopol there
is no time to give the dead dignity
no respectful burial thrown instead into
a trench filling with bodies
one after another
in scenes we thought were consigned to
the middle of the last century but
happening now in a european city
the only thing i want is for this to be
finished i don't know who's guilty who's
right who started this
damn them all those people who started
this
1200 have been killed in attacks ripping
apart the city's streets and homes
launched by one of the world's most
advanced militaries reducing living in
the seaside resort town to a struggle to
survive in another resort this one in
turkey russia's foreign minister arrives
smiling for the highest level talks
since the invasion began but after just
an hour and a half they ended with
ukraine's foreign minister emerging
sounding frustrated my impression is
that russia is
not in a position at this point
to
establish a ceasefire
they seek
a surrender from ukraine this is not
what they are going to get
then the russians turn sergey lavrov is
a sharp operator who chooses his words
carefully but listen to this and wonder
what planet he's on
we're not planning to attack other
countries would it not attack ukraine
you said some time ago that russia had
no intention to invade ukraine i think
today you've said that russia did not
invade ukraine when it clearly has
why should the ukrainians take you
seriously with all due respect why
should they believe a word you say and
the rest of the world
this is not about ukraine this is about
the aggression against anything russian
interests religion language culture
safety
and of course now the reaction of the
west to our actions very aggressive
reaction
russia has sent its foreign minister
here to talk peace but without a mandate
to discuss ceasefires or a new
humanitarian aid corridor claim the
ukrainians it's hard to see what these
talks have achieved apart from the fact
that they have happened and could happen
again
in versailles in france european leaders
met to discuss ukraine but know the
worst strategy of using sanctions to
deter russian aggression has so far
failed
russia's advance is being blocked its
tanks here picked off one by one but the
more its military fails the more
barbaric it seems its tactics and the
more the people of ukraine suffer its
onslaught
dominic wagon sky news and talia
let's bring in our moscow correspondent
diana magnay and diana how have these
talks today been viewed
by the kremlin
well there's been no follow-up from the
kremlin on the talks between uh russia's
foreign minister and his ukrainian
counterpart but we do know that vladimir
putin had a phone call with the south
african president later this afternoon
and briefed him on the talks
and also on what russia insists on
calling its special military operation
in ukraine um and uh we've just heard
from cyril ramaphosa that uh he was
asked he has been asked to mediate try
and find a negotiated settlement to this
crisis so that means that you have um
turkey israel and south africa all
offering a hand a mediating hand in this
process but we certainly don't seem to
be any closer to any kind of compromise
certainly as far as those talks in the
morning went we also know that vladimir
putin spoke to his german and french
counterparts in a joint phone call this
morning and both of them urged an
immediate ceasefire um and said a
negotiated solution was the only way out
of all of this um
further to what uh sergey lavrov said in
that
press conference about the bombing of a
hospital in um mariupol of the maternity
hospital
russia's ministry of defense has now
said that that was a staged information
provocation by the kiev regime now i'm
sure that the kiev regime will push back
very hard on that and we heard earlier
from president zielenski
saying
war crimes are not possible without
propagandists who cover them up so you
can see the kind of rhetoric on both
sides about that
terrible bombing in mariupol that we
witnessed yesterday
we've also had interesting developments
on the economic front i mean the last
week in moscow just seeing all the
foreign companies that have pulled up
the shops that have boarded up um and of
course foreign companies pulling out
across the whole country uh vladimir
putin had a meeting with his cabinet and
to discuss how to mitigate the effect of
sanctions and he said that russia would
have to adapt uh but that it would come
out uh stronger um and that he would
continue to to to to deal essentially
with those countries that weren't uh
cooperating with the sanctions regime on
russia he also said that uh and this is
following a conversation that's been
going on for a few days now
that russia might place or would
consider placing foreign assets uh idled
foreign assets here in russia under
external administration effectively
bringing in russian managers um to make
sure that supply chains and russian
staff were kept in jobs now that's a
pretty dramatic uh proposition
essentially nationalizing um foreign
assets for companies that have moved out
and vladimir putin who's one of the
biggest
businessmen in this country
interestingly turn around and said we
should approach that kind of thing with
extreme caution it would set russia back
a hundred years um and it would mean
that uh investors would mistrust russia
for decades to come
diana thank you very much let's go to
our international affairs editor then
dominic waghorn
who is in
turkey and dominic if if sergey lavrov
is saying that
russia has not invaded
ukraine i mean what kind of hope is
there going forward
yeah i mean he's a well-respected
diplomat he's someone who chooses his
words carefully was he there just
sticking to the script because don't
forget russia has banned describing this
invasion as an invasion uh and banned
the use of the word war says it's a
special military operation or was he
engaging in something more sinister was
this kind of orwellian double speak
where you say one thing but you mean the
other because what he said there was
that uh russia has no intention of
invading any other countries in fact he
says russia has not invaded ukraine so i
think policymakers in the west will be
looking that and trying to read whether
there's a further threat there and if
you look at vladimir putin's speeches he
has made it pretty clear that the
grievance he feels acting over on
ukraine is also a grievance he harbours
over the baltic states as well and there
is uh certainly a way of interpreting
what he said about ukraine suggesting
that he may well do the same in the
baltic states but what we saw
effectively in these talks were compete
failure to reach any ceasefire any
further humanitarian aid court or
agreements the russians kept saying we
have to refer back to moscow as they've
been saying in belarus as well and on
the russian side it was really a
masterclass of misinformation we had
various conflicting stories about that
maternity hospital in mario pole as dina
was saying there the russian minister of
defense now saying that this was staged
by the ukrainians
earlier on today uh maria
zakharova the russian minister foreign
ministry spokesperson today uh said that
that these pictures were fake her then
boss then went on to say no he believed
the attack did happen carried out by the
russian military but it was targeting uh
ukrainian nazis built uh who were basing
their activities um within that building
so two contradictory versions of the
same event there which is typical
russian misinformation i think we're
going to see more of that in the weeks
and months to come but i think the
crucial fact that's come out of the talk
today is they haven't achieved anything
there is an agreement to meet uh on this
sort of higher level if you like again
and again but based on what we've seen
today i think hopes have to be managed
as to whether this diplomacy is going to
achieve anything
yeah okay dominic thank you very much
indeed for that well
it was once a normal hospital on the
outskirts of kiev now it's the nearest
medical facility to the front line and
is given over entirely to treating
wounded ukrainian soldiers the staff
have no training in treating shrapnel
injuries or gunshot wounds but now find
themselves part of the war effort
against the russian invaders and a
warning our special correspondent alex
crawford's report does show some
distressing images
they arrive stuffed into car boots
and on the back seats they're taking
some terrible hits trying to stop the
russian troops entering the ukrainian
capital
laid out on already blood-soaked
stretchers
the soldiers have just been shelled on a
front line which is creeping ever closer
to keith
and it's the nearest hospital now
entirely turned over to dealing with the
war wounded
these aren't army medics they're the
towns doctors and nurses who two weeks
ago were dealing with births and bone
breaks
now they plunged into a new world spent
trying to save the lives of soldiers and
civilians torn apart by bombs and
bullets
it's world war three it's very versatile
and it could be stopped here or it could
move through the whole world and throw
all the dots please help us to stop this
world
they are shell-shocked and shaking
and so far the politicians peace talks
have got nowhere
hospitals are protected locations under
international law but no one here trusts
that to be observed yet there's an
astonishing resilience and perhaps a
realization they have no option
it's not difficult for us to fight he
tells us we're defending our land and
will continue to protect it
but then he delivers a rousing call not
just to his fellow ukrainian men and
women but also the rest of the world
everyone has to stand together he says
glory to ukraine our army will win
this is on the northwest edge of the
capital and we found multiple vehicles
and homes which had been hit apparently
indiscriminately
there seems to be no shortage of lucky
escapes he was on duty as an emergency
worker
his house five houses from here
there are thousands of lives abruptly
halted by this wall
pets abandoned in the rush to keep out
of the way of the rockets and bombs
families who've upped and left
everything just to try to survive
there's a constant sound of artillery
and shelling going on and you can see
the devastation that some of the attacks
have already had
we know
according to the locals here that the
russians are only a few kilometers down
the road and this
is the constant backdrop
so those who can't or won't leave live
in a shadowy underground world below the
booming war sounds
about half of the capital's population
has fled the city according to the mayor
it smells good
smells good
these are the bravest of women tending
to some of the community's most
vulnerable and most frightened
we've already learned how to tell the
difference between our side's shooting
and the enemies natalia tells us we can
identify everything and we're just
trying to keep everyone calm
they're already living under siege here
with sons and partners fighting and
their homes bombed
it says
for sure this is a crime and putin has
to be punished she tells us
hi dan
those fleeing include a former british
soldier who'd been living in butcher had
to pass through russian troops to escape
and saw dozens of civilian targets had
been attacked
events i saw a lot of vehicles civilian
vehicles destroyed on the road uh dead
bodies still inside has thrown onto the
road um even vehicles people have been
marking their vehicles with the
ukrainian or the russian word for child
on their vehicles if they have children
a bunch of those vehicles were also
destroyed with children
they're engaged in the fight of their
lives to stop the russian troops
advancing any further
but their president's warning much more
of their blood will be spilled unless
his nation gets international military
support
alex crawford sky news on the edge of
the capital kyiv
well chelsea football club is facing
huge restrictions on the way it operates
after its owner roman abramovich was
sanctioned by the uk government mr
abramovic is one of seven russian
billionaires to face new curbs which
include asset freezes and travel bans
that ministers say it's part of a move
against those linked to the russian
regime the restrictions mean games can
still go ahead players can be paid but
not bought or sold and no new tickets
can be sold sky's ali fortescue repeal
reports
he is britain's best known oligarch
but roman abramovich's two decades at
chelsea an enviable london property
portfolio have been undone by his links
to russia and to president putin
abramovich's assets and the club that he
transformed frozen his name added to the
list of billionaires sanctioned by
britain it's important that he doesn't
benefit from the club our priority is to
ensure that the club is protected that
the fans are protected and the national
game
it's an extraordinary moment for foreign
policy and for football chelsea will now
have to operate under a special license
that means season ticket holders can go
to games but fans can't buy new tickets
they'll be subject to a transfer ban
blocked from negotiating new contracts
the club can't sell merchandise three
have already suspended their sponsorship
and whilst reasonable travel costs for
players will be covered longer trips
abroad could be difficult
all the fans all over the world are
devastated right now they've gone too
far with this
i think they've like obviously there's a
massive issue in ukraine but him leaving
it's just
i feel like
the club's just dying
right now the value of the our club in
terms of achievements quality of players
location
i'm not worried
a little setback but we banged back
stronger
the government would have been making
sure their case was absolutely legally
watertight before sanctioning roman
abramovich it is a big move it means he
faces a uk travel ban and his assets
including chelsea are frozen and that
makes the process of selling this club
much more complicated
the billionaire had already confirmed
that chelsea's being sold the profits he
said will go to victims of the war in
ukraine it effectively would have to be
sold
via the approval of the government or
the government appointing someone to
work alongside the sellers to ensure
that any sale proceeds went into an
account which could not be accessed by
roman labranovich i think it does call
into question uh the the premier
league's approach to
allowing individuals to come in and buy
football clubs without having any form
of
human rights
clauses
six others have also been sanctioned
today among them mr abramovich's former
business partner oleg deripaska an eagle
section whose yacht was seized by the
french last week
but for the man so deeply entwined in
british football lauded even recently by
some of the most high-profile players
whose name less than a week ago was a
rallying cry from chelsea fans at
burnley
it is a moment many believed wouldn't
come chelsea's game tonight against
norwich will go ahead what happens next
for the club is much less certain ali
fortescue sky news
this is sky news tonight coming up will
a new digital visa application scheme
make it easier for the thousands of
refugees desperate to reach their
families in the uk
[Music]
i am there to speak truth
question
to
power
the questions that people want to answer
when i'm interviewing a politician it's
a more rapid fire but this is not this
is a conversation the format of the show
so i'm going to have an hour-long
interview show once a week on a thursday
night it's at 9pm it's a moment to press
pause on this frenetic pace of news and
just reflect on things and when we do
have a politician on the show you might
see them interviewed by me in a
different way than you perhaps normally
see it what they do
why they do it if i can find some of
that and bring it onto sky news i'd be
really happy
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to ukraine there's to be a
change
in the uk's visa scheme for ukrainians
seeking sanctuary in britain from
tuesday the process will go digital so
people with a passport won't need to go
to an application center in europe it
should speed up the process but it still
excludes anyone without a passport the
home secretary has faced fierce
criticism that the uk dragged its feet
in response to the refugee crisis
sky's laura bundock reports from lille
in northern france
a fortnight ago they had jobs schools
and homes
now they are refugees
three cousins and their four children
in the port yeah
we sit in the floor within hours waiting
10 hours
with kids
they have family in the uk
but seven long visa forms all in english
took hours
every time is different information
every two hours
some change change changes in need plus
new documents plus new translators
everything's new
some family help in ukraine and send
and made and now we make everything seem
translated
yeah so you've had to have family in
ukraine send you yeah information yes
mom is her mother
it is unbelievably difficult with their
husbands in kiev now fighters
they just want somewhere safe to stay we
don't need some
benefit we don't need nothing because we
have his family we need some one two
three or three months i don't know
when this situation in ukraine is really
good we are just back
and everyone here has a similar story
things aren't just complicated they are
constantly changing a day ago people
were brought here from calais where they
were told there was a visa center
opening nearby in lille
now they're told it'll open on friday
not here but in harass and that's an
arrow away
[Music]
some have made it through in the early
hours maria brought her ukrainian mum to
edinburgh people have nowhere to go some
people like run out of money people like
stay
they have no home they just want to make
to their fam like to their family
and the whole process is just is too
long too complicated
after days on the road they're all off
to paris to finish the applications does
it feel welcoming to you the uk
no he's not so welcome no
yeah
but we try we're strong yeah yeah
they've left their hearts in ukraine but
their hope now lies in britain
laura bunduck sky news in lille
this is sky news tonight coming up
the former head of nato and as uh
rasmussen tells sky news nothing should
be off the table when it comes to
dealing with russia that and more after
the break
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to western ukraine the
former nato secretary general anderso
rasmussen has told me that nato may need
to act sooner rather than later to
intervene in this conflict mr rasmussen
said the decision to rule out a no-fly
zone is encouraging vladimir putin to
commit more atrocities i spoke to him a
little earlier and asked him whether the
situation on the ground could further
deteriorate
i think they will get worse because the
russians are not
advancing as planned so putin will get
more desperate
and that will lead to more devastating
warfare
how do you think
putin can be stopped
you know what more must be done do you
think to stop him
first of all i think we should step up
our delivery of
weapons
to the ukrainians
they have demonstrated a great bravery
and we should help them all we can
so we should help them with drones with
anti-tank equipment
uh
better
air defense systems etc etc
we've seen the attacks on civilians
we've seen the attack on the hospital
is there not now a moral case a
humanitarian case for a more significant
military
intervention given what is happening
here now maybe a no-fly zone or
something like that
it is indeed heartbreaking to watch the
images of russian bombings
of civilians so at this stage i would
not exclude
anything i think it's a mistake
that western leaders are busy excluding
this and that action we are confronted
with a political gangster in the kremlin
and in defense against gangsters you
should not exclude any action
so would you be thinking seriously now
about something like a no-fly zone or
some other military intervention here
first of all i would declare economic
war against
russia i think
that's what is needed here and now to
stop
the revenue
from oil and gas
purchase
in russia to completely cut russia off
the international economic
system
but concerning the no-fly zone
i think
it should still be on the table
it could be to protect
humanitarian corridors
it could be to protect the western
ukraine but
let's be clear-eyed about this the
russians would consider it a declaration
of war
absolutely but by ruling it out you
think do you that it is in some ways
encouraging
uh vladimir putin
absolutely because vladimir putin
only respects one thing
force and determination and unity
so we shouldn't exclude anything
he should be kept in doubt about our
intentions but here now i think we
should stop the revenue that finances
his war so i would suggest that the
european union immediately
stop
all purchase of oil and gas
from
russia
so what is the red line for you
militarily if it if nato is not going to
act now and they've acted before in
places like libya and so forth if nato
is not going to act now what does it
take for nato to act militarily i think
we should follow the development
very closely and
if
russia continues
to target civilians bombing of hospitals
as we have seen not to speak about if
they use chemical weapons uh in ukraine
i would consider that crossing a red
line
and that would mean military action
which could lead to a broader war but
you would still go ahead with that would
you
of course we have to
think this through very thoroughly
because
a no-fly zone
might
make more harm than good
by expanding the conflict beyond
ukraine's borders and and of course
we don't want that and that's why i
think here and now my preferred option
would be actually to declare an outright
economic war against
russia by stopping the purchase of
oil and gas and actually we can handle
it
in europe
it will be tough it will come at a price
but that price would be very low
compared to the current suffering of the
ukrainian people and it would be a tiny
price compared to the loss of freedom if
we do not act now
i think you've met um mr putin how far
do you think he is prepared to go in all
this
i'm concerned that he won't stop
in ukraine if he succeeds in ukraine
next step could be moldova and georgia
and in the worst case also
against the baltic states so we may
have a choice between confronting mr
putin now or later
and history has taught us
that
the suffering
and the losses
might be
less
by confronting such dictators at an
early stage
rather than too late and if nato did act
now maybe militarily
do you think that putin would back down
yeah i i
at least i think if he gets uh good
advice he would realize that russia has
no chance whatsoever against nato but
again let me stress
i do not want a military
confrontation with
russia
i think a declaration of economic war
would be more efficient
do you think that vladimir putin is
behaving irrationally do you think he's
behaving delusionally over all this
mr putin is definitely
behaving irrationally
because rational thinking
wouldn't have led him to attack uh
ukraine
and he has
i mean he has been through an incredible
change of mind
i met him first time in 2002
at that time he enthusiastically argued
in favor of a strengthened cooperation
between russia and the west
since then he changed his mind attacked
georgia attacked ukraine so he has
changed his mind over time and just
finally do you think there is a
diplomatic way out of this
and soon
it's hard to see
because
russia has
presented what i would call maximalistic
demands that eventually would lead to
the dissolution
of ukraine as an independent and
sovereign state
of course we have to adhere to the
principle that all sovereign countries
have a right to decide their lives
affiliation themselves
and and and that's exactly what putin
tries
to
deprive
ukraine of that right
putin is obsessed by the idea to restore
the greatness of russia that's why he
wants to control the territory of the
former soviet union and we shouldn't
allow him to do that
okay andersfo rasmussen thank you very
much indeed
welcome
well as a refugee exodus continues out
of ukraine poland has so far accepted
over a million people many polls feel a
sense of solidarity with their ukrainian
neighbours fearing the dominance of
course of russia
approaching their own country some have
gladly offered to house families fleeing
the war the authorities have allowed
people to cross the border with very
little bureaucracy in contrast to the uk
but with so many flooding into poland
the strain is now beginning to show
skies lisa holland reports from warsaw
it's just two weeks since poland became
a beacon of sanctuary for ukrainian
refugees
now by their own admission the capital
warsaw is just about coping and close to
being overwhelmed
at the central station a sea of people
some just off trains from ukraine hungry
thirsty and tired
but the refugees are grateful to
volunteers for the most basic of things
like a toothbrush and helping them get
back on their feet
i had to
change the money for her because there
is a queue so we have to go and take the
ticket you've got a lot of people that
you need to help
as you can see
just not stopping is it it's not well it
is it's just i don't know how long it's
going to be but probably for a long time
warsaw has welcomed the equivalent of 15
of its previous population and nobody
knows how many are staying
where do you plan to go to we don't know
i don't know
no idea
no no we have no idea
having arrived safely from ukraine the
refugees then need somewhere to go or
stay
these people are queuing for a bus for
germany they have no idea when it will
leave or even which city they'll end up
in
some have slept rough for days waiting
for somewhere else to go
others like gregory and his 87 year old
mother who can barely walk just want to
reach a european country where they have
friends
we have no
[Music]
home we have no
cars we have no nothing only these three
baggages oh that's all
this family would like to go to the uk
but aren't eligible as they have no
family ties but they can see the
pressure mounting on the authorities in
warsaw
we are going to germany because too much
our citizens in poland we don't we don't
want to bother poland
people
warsaw says it needs help calling on the
rest of europe and the uk to step up
i am afraid that this is just a
beginning
so i think you could
today think about
your offer for them if you could
provide something
it would be really welcome
the refugee crisis is getting worse by
the day which means it's likely to be a
long time before any of these people
truly find some peace
lisa holland sky news warsaw
this is sky news tonight coming up
it'll make life difficult for chelsea
but what else will freezing roman
abramovich's assets achieve we'll talk
to an anti-corruption activist next
[Music]
[Music]
independent united kingdom
[Music]
[Applause]
these last few years have seen some huge
stories
[Music]
and these stories have been driven by
politics by politicians the people in
power
you must stay at home and it's my job to
figure out how these decisions made by
politicians impact all of us in our
everyday lives this is the worst thing
i've ever been through in my life people
turn up here with their child stuff in a
black sack and just say i don't want to
and that is what it is it's first class
poverty
is this an example of the welfare state
failing
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
these are stories that affect us all
millions of children are now having to
catch up
some stories have changed all of our
lives because like the residents the
staff are being infected
politicians they make decisions all of
the time and it's our job to hold them
to account i wonder if you will take
this opportunity to apologize to those
families but in the end the real power
doesn't actually lie with the
politicians
the real power
lies with the people
i'm nick martin i'm the people and
politics correspondent at sky news
we're going to talk more now about
sanctions and the decision to freeze the
assets of roman abramovich it's left
chelsea football club in a kind of
suspended animation still functioning
but unable to sign new players negotiate
new contracts sell new tickets
or sell any merchandise well i'm joined
now by roman borisovich who's a
political campaigner and anti-corruption
activist thank you very much for being
with us the government statement is an
extraordinary one
clear about uh brahmovich's links to
putin but also suggesting that he may be
linked through
one of his companies to this
destabilization of ukraine
pretty
um well i guess you know uh
putin is uh
the real owner of abramovich's assets
and this is uh
finally a their realization is finally
coming to the west that uh uh whatever
you want to call him trustee uh wallet
but the the money that abram which is
managing is not entirely his and that's
been very clear from the moment when he
bought chelsea uh the the transaction
that was viewed as uh making him uh a
very rich person was really legitimizing
uh russian kleptocracies putin's uh
money in in london
so what impact will this have then on
him
as an individual and do you think other
countries may act as well
i would sincerely hope so because you
know uk is not enough and the
efforts uh in with regard to these uh
oligarchs need to be truly global uh
abram which has uh properties and assets
in france and in the states uh all over
the globe so freezing of essence has to
be truly global we can't really freeze
chelsea here and let him enjoy uh his
palaces and friends and his uh
you know uh goodwill beach property in
some parts
so what happens then to his uh homes in
london um his yachts and so forth what
what will happen now to all that
well now his assets will be froze as
this is the measure that uh the
government has taken these uh due to the
uh
the military conflict in ukraine
technically if the conflict stops
tomorrow it has to be unfrozen and
returned to abramovic well what happens
to the assets after that
entirely depends on the political will
of downing street is there if there is a
will to investigate his links to kremlin
is there if there is a will to prove
that this is putin's money it has to be
confiscated and most likely given back
to the people of ukraine
so
just explain how he was benefiting from
his close links to uh vladimir putin
um
he was he was as i said a trustee if you
want to think about in these terms he
was managing money that is not entirely
his uh he was allowed to have
planes and or maybe told to have planes
to uh under underscore the largest of
russian uh
oligarchs abroad and to create an image
of a very uh
successful uh independent businessman
which he is not and uh the
this is gonna be very painful for putin
to see his assets frozen and and and his
proxy uh be not able to manage his his
money
so what do you think he'll do now i mean
will he
just go back and live in russia what
will he do do you think
um i think he'll find himself some other
place
uh on earth i don't think think he wants
to go back to russia um
nobody wants to go back to russia with
these economic sanctions and especially
people who are used to the life of
luxury
so what he's i think he's living in
israel at the moment isn't he
he'll probably stay there and it's very
convenient because israel doesn't have
extradition treaty so he will be off
limits to any law enforcement that wants
to
to penalize him for his uh uh criminal
cryptocracy
and i'm not sure his lawyers will be
fighting it roman uh berisovich thank
you very much indeed for
being with us this evening appreciate
your time thank you thank you very much
this is uh sky news tonight coming up in
the next hour all the latest
developments on the conflict uh here in
ukraine as the prime minister tells sky
news he fears russia may use chemical
weapons dermot monahan is next
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]